[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rick and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we tackle the question what
would you do if robots took your job all
of a sudden we have a whole we have a
whole due to automation using of
television career needs to change yeah
that's right Bush is the inciting event
of buddy system season two now that's
right to promote that but we could
promote it and what did you do when you
lost your job to robots well we can talk
about that when we talk about it yeah
because there's a lot of parallels
between our buddy system season two
characters and the real us even though
it's it's it's us in a parallel universe
by the way they're releasing buddy
system season two I don't know if we're
in front of the paywall at some point so
be on point be looking for that it will
make a big deal about it when it's all
there
seasons 1 & 2 but if you're gonna only
watch one watch season 2 that's
confusing unintentional plug I guess you
can watch season 1 but anyway yeah
there's a there's some robot stuff
happening there and just let me say this
whole conversation it it spawned from a
reddit session you call them sessions
yeah I have a reddit session as I'm
sleeping well and I sleep as I'm going
to sleep in my bed there's that's
another thing we may need to tackle is
if that's a good habit but I went down
this reddit rabbit trail which meanders
through manufacturing processes some
eerie anecdotes and lands smack dab on
you I'm featured in this reddit thread
likely I don't want to say too much but
I will say well I will you know what yes
this reddit thread that was featured on
the home page had nothing absolutely in
the world to do with you us anything to
do with us at all somehow
involved you Wow I'm suddenly interested
in that so it was a wild ride on reddit
and now I want to take you back through
it I'm participate in this discussion
the robots are gonna take over at some
point in our conversation okay but we're
gonna land on you inexplicably great on
it well unexploited explain it but it's
unexpected okay before we get into that
I do want to tell you something that
happened to me at a party first of all
let me just say that you're a party
animal I say it have been so occupied in
the evenings
tonight we'll mark the sixth straight
night that I have had something that is
like kind of like an involved an
obligation obligation and out of the
home thing in this one tonight my my
wife is actually gonna go with me and
we're going to say we're going to the
the Mayans emcee season two premiere
that's right to support our friend Kurt
Sutter and and this is the one that
Jesse's going with me to and she and she
was and I just wanna I was like you
ready for tonight and she was like what
again she was like you're going
somewhere again I was like you're going
with me and it didn't seem to make a
difference
yeah that's why Chrissy's not going I am
going I'm going with you and Jesse and
and I guess Stevie's my date
yeah cuz Kristi yeah she's like listen
this have been too much stuff happening
and I mean if it wasn't for like a sense
of well I want to go for what it is but
I don't want to go because it's just
going somewhere else I understand that
and I said I said listen and I'm almost
like you're going that's good enough as
if both of us are going that's enough
support but that's kind of lame I'm not
gonna do that I appreciate that I could
change my mind I could bail I would
surprise but I
I certainly hope you go
but it has been too much and then I say
this is not typical she's like you
always say that but it isn't I don't do
things six nights in a row it's not
typical that's not the kind of life I
have man right by the way I have
something the next two nights two so
that's another factor oh really
yeah I got like well you maybe you'll
beat my streak welcome back to school
nights two different schools in the end
you will probably tie me I did something
on Thursday and then on Saturday you
only did something on Friday we went to
the Kacey Musgraves concert with our
wives that was fabulous it's a great
time yeah cuz I loved that woman
cuz I went to the Rolling Stones concert
the night before oh you dig out the
Rolling Stone hazard yeah man I'm so I'm
tempted to talk about that first of all
I freaking love Kacey Musgraves I mean
she's me I just the album is amazing
she played most of it it was wonderful
it's exactly what I love to listen to
but I gotta say seeing the Rolling
Stones who I would not call myself a
huge stones fan before going to see them
that was absolutely amazing everybody in
the Rose Bowl was just in awe of the
fact that these like how old how old it
I say Mick was 76 76 years old four
months after having a heart valve
replacement surgery he's what he's
strutting around the stage for two hours
going an estimated 14 miles total so
crazy I know it's just and they sounded
good because the Devils in him that's
how he's able to do he had sympathy for
the devil man me and Britain had a great
time it was his treat it was a long time
coming because the heart valve
replacement but man I get it I get the
stones now I feel like I'm an insider I
got the lips and the tongue on my shirt
oh gosh yeah good look best band logo
maybe of all time it is I mean I kind of
feel like going to to the Rolling Stones
and then Kacey Musgraves like 90 it's
not the ideal because you're gonna yeah
you're gonna judge Kacey Musgraves
show woman ship versus
The Rolling Stones which is just that
she's doing a different thing oh
absolutely but anyway you went to a
party I went to the one thing that you
didn't go to and let's call it a
fundraiser it was a fundraiser for a
charity that were involved with and
there was a guy there who I've met a
couple of times it's the older guy I
mean he's older than me and super like
super nice guy and we were having a
bunch of interesting conversations about
some stuff that he was that he was
involved with but one of the things that
he needed to show me we got into a
conversation about jackfruit jackfruit
yeah and I recently had seen how big a
jackfruit could be have you seen how big
a jackfruit could be I can't even say I
know what a jackfruit actually okay so
do you know what a grapefruit no not
like a grapefruit no so you know when
you go to like a vegan restaurant and
they've got like barbecue but it's not
barbecue it's something else oh yeah
often it's this jackfruit thing kind of
stringy yes it's got an interesting
texture to it
that's jackfruit and so yeah looks like
that it's gonna spiky on the outside
it's green the color of an avocado it
shaped like
how big is okay well how big would you
think that that was just looking it
looked about as big as an avocado or an
apple it's this big what they can be 70
things like this was said I twice the
size of a what an average watermelon so
what yes so when I went to kid great
that fruit is jacked this guy's actually
helping to import some jackfruit and in
into California and jackfruit is like
exploding in popularity right so and I
adjust with LOC at the grocery store a
week ago had seen a jackfruit and I was
like wow and that's a jackfruit it's
that big and we almost got it as like a
gag gift for Jesse let's bring home this
jackfruit and see what she does with it
you know thing cuz it was just so big
well anyway we start talking about is
the business that he's involved in
getting jackfruits in and he's like oh I
gotta show you this I gotta show you
this one I found so he takes out his
phone and began scrolling through his
photos and he's like okay hold on no I'm
getting close uh no nothing's okay just
moving his thumb like this and just
rifling through hundreds thousands
photos okay two and a half minutes into
the scrolling and the saying I'm almost
there is it missing I begin to think
that I am the victim of a YouTube prank
video you started looking around for I
think I begin to think that I might be
on what would you do with John Key onus
which incidentally I think is a YouTube
channel now what would you do if
somebody scrolled forever like how long
would it take in their scrolling for you
to just jump in and stop it did you
think about that hey man you know what
just email it to me well at one point I
was like yeah yeah I know they're big
man as I guess I wanted the grocery
store he's like no no you got to see
this one two and a half minutes is a
long time to watch somebody scroll well
I know are you looking over his shoulder
on his phone and is he scrolling through
nothing but photos of jackfruit
he stood lots of photos of fruits other
things that he imports he's like hood
this is my girlfriend and this is when
we went to the beach and you know no no
he's my dog he is he is that's dog
laughing through a grid of photos it's
like a wound on my dog I had to send
this to the vet he's not giving any up
in any commentary on the stuff that he's
scrolling through he's just saying oh
there and you keep saying it okay here
and then it's not there and then he
keeps going now you know me I'm a I'm a
nice man and I you're nicer to strangers
I have a high tolerance for this kind of
behavior I don't know if it's average
tolerance or is either average or higher
tolerance
well you have a higher tolerance than I
do oh let's at least say that and so I
was like what am I gonna do like I had
time to start having like an existential
crisis like because every time I look
back he was just saying haircut and so I
was just like I guess I'm just gonna
stay here in the moment I'm gonna let
this guy find his big-ass jackfruit and
then when I see it I'm gonna be really
impressed so I did that well it's kind
of a lot of build up so it's pretty
we beets oh so he did find it it is
really big he found it yeah yeah it was
very large yeah you're not even telling
that part of the story oh yeah he did
find it was what the story's over it was
said I mean but the freaking jack 470
pounds the jackfruit was 70 pounds 70
pounds
that's all three three feet tall I don't
know gosh what what gave you a sense of
scale the own opinion him holding him
holding it good gosh they can get Jack
first big get big I bet they don't taste
as good of course they never taste like
a big catfish you don't ever gross like
gawrsh
you could put you could put feet on that
in a snout and it would be like a vegan
pig it's literally as big as a pig
jackfruit takes on the flavors of
whatever it's a lot like tofu takes on
the flavors but let's get back to the
scrolling well cuz I do want to talk
about you know what he got back to the
scroll again after he found the
jackfruit
he's a scroller another I lost count
three to four times he had something in
his mind he wanted to show me and he
would go back to the photos and then I
don't think it was ever as long as that
first time but I was like this is like a
Seinfeld episode if I felt was made in
20 nights yeah he's the scroller now you
know what somebody needs to talk to him
because he's too dependent on photos he
needs to just do hand gesture you know
like this big or pick up a small child
and be like it was this big or or make
it his wallpaper if he if if the
anecdote comes up that often you need to
have it you need to have it printed on a
business card I think this is a perfect
example of why you need favorites
you need to take advantage of your
favorites feature on your photo
collection yeah you tell me you tell
them I'm making an album if you need
like oh there's the photo of me with my
kids here's the photo of the big-ass
jackfruit that the story stories I
always tell but then spend way too much
time scrolling for the payoff photo
album that's what you call it I've
actually thought a lot about this like
okay good pausing a story to scroll
because actually on the way to the
Rolling Stones concert we were in an
uber Britt and I were both in the
backseat and this guy was like this guy
was coming on strong like he wanted to
know everything about us and like really
you think well was it of uber drivers
those are the worst had something
hanging from his mirror that said fish
the band oh so then Britain starts
talking about fish they didn't like
literally for 20 minutes the two of them
are just talking about fish and I'm like
this is great I don't want to be a part
of this yeah I'm just over here looking
out the window looking at my phone and
but the guy like he made such a
connection with Britney was like oh he's
an artist he was like I used to be a
producer but I only charge $15 an hour
and he had just he had this hard luck
story and then he's like give me give me
your information to put in my phone let
me give you my information to put in
your phone so you like made Britain like
put his name and number in his phone and
then he's like and then he pulls up a
notepad and he's like writing down
Britain's information I'm like he's not
coming from me he's like what about you
what's your name
you know it's like 30 minutes in Drive
Charles that's when you say Charles I
think I said I think I said link because
maybe I was thinking about that I you
have the best excuse in the world
I say James quite a bit mommy Starbucks
my freaking name is James he was like
and what do you do for a living and I
was like I froze and I was like I'm a
video producer this is the last guy on
earth I wanted to get you video producer
he was like what kind of what kind of
videos I was like I'm digital I was like
I was like corporate videos No
what you you lie man I said I'm a
corporate well I know what we are
corporation on a corporate platform
Google as a corporation we're a
corporation and we're a corporation you
can lie on a couple of levels I make
corporate videos and I said I like to
think that if people don't watch my
videos they would what was Britain doing
when you said corporate videos are
typically like safety videos
I never made eye contact with Britain I
was pretty I was pretty ashamed of what
I was doing a video producer of
corporate videos mr. Charles please stop
with my point oh yeah and then he then
he goes back to talking about the fish
conscious hey hey mission accomplished
mission accomplished and he's like he's
like man I was I was on the front row of
this show and like he starts scrolling
through his he's scrolling and driving
he's scrolling and driving well we're in
bumper-to-bumper traffic in the Rose
Bowl all right we're trapped with this
guy it could be an hour or trap with a
scroller and now he's scrolling and his
phone's up they're mounted it's not I
mean I'm like what's it what [ __ ] should
I look away should I look at his photos
he's not scrolling that quickly and he's
saying things like I said he was like oh
this is me and my girl at the beach yeah
this is this is like a screenshot I took
a something it's like no he's well you
think he's giving he's a commentary
Laden scroller which is better than a
non comment but I feel like you should
look away
it's kind of like when somebody is
entering their password like if if if
you want to help somebody with their
laptop like an in-law or something like
you want to avert your eyes when they
put their password in you know what I'm
saying I do I don't see how it's
relevant but I appreciate when
somebody's scrolling through their
entire photo like you're seeing into
their life
jackfruit you never know what you might
see and I don't there's lots of things I
don't want to see an uber driver do you
know I'm sad I got it yeah you know
that's a different album I'd like to see
him just drive and be quiet he actually
talked about he made it he made a
comment about man ivory I really enjoyed
talking to you and this is in the middle
of a conversation not the talking to
Brittany he's like because a lot of
people don't get in the car and they're
like you know they'll just you're like
dip so just like be quiet I'm like I'm a
human you're human
and I'm thinking that's me man yeah I
don't really think you can call that a
dip I know he's kind of harsh I mean
some people just don't want to have a
conversation and then he's like I'm
a-coming to this show
later and then he's i'ma pull you guys
right up here and he's like he goes
through the parking there like charging
like 20 bucks for parking he's like I'm
just dropping these guys off so they let
him go through and then he's like I'm
not leaving and then it dawns on me as
he's pulling into a parking space this
guy is gonna be with us all night
and then he's like he's parking the car
he's like I'm gonna give you five stars
and I'm coming I'm coming to the show
it's like do you guys have an extra
ticket and I was like no thank goodness
we don't have an extra day coming to the
show do you have an extra yeah coming to
the show unless you can get a ticket
right so then then we split up but for a
second I thought he was gonna be with us
all night because he already had a
ticket I think you would have you would
have shut that down I would have I think
absolutely I think even I would have
shut that down but I wouldn't have
stared it as scrolling see I I'm still
I'm human and I think people who have a
low capacity or high capacity for
tolerating scrolling have a low capacity
for exposing people to scrolling like
I'd work I've got like I'll scroll for
12 seconds and then I feel like I'm
inconveniencing somebody I'm like you
know what I don't worry about it
I think I'll Google photos you can you
could type in jackfruit and it would
literally pull up you can do that on the
iPhone as well and I almost told him
that but I just didn't I didn't he was
thousand images for him right so all
right so that we could talk about that
forever but we're gonna talk about go
down another robot wild rabbit trail but
first you can get this shirt that I'm
wearing which is part of the post appall
collapse collection at mythical calm
this is one of three different shirts
you can get there's also I don't know
what's still there we got hats we've got
a bandana we've got the sweatpants were
big hit yeah and I think those are still
up there get them while they're still
there
lots of stuff constantly updated at
mythical calm rip you boys check it out
support intern attainment
and feel good like it literally feels
good to wear stuff it feels good and
it's just a cool shirt it's like you're
not like hey if you're the kind of
person who's like hey I'm a fan of this
show and you don't want to be that
person you're like hey I got a cool
shirt on well this is for the cool shirt
folks ok let's get into this you know I
have this habit of laying in bed and I
like I just pull up the reddit thread
because it just sends me into a world
that's not my own there's many things
that many threads that I follow that a
relaxing educational entertaining
mesmerizing but in no way related to my
work whereas if I pull up Twitter then
that's a problem because I feel like
even if I just look at tweets of
comedians I start to get anxiety
interest anxiety with a G because I just
feel like I can is it's the commits a
social media trap of comparison I think
I'd do it on that level and like a some
sort of professional level and then you
even on Instagram well I know we did a
whole episode about it but that's
starting to creep in so like a little
bit of that but it's mostly just like
exotic locations that I look at on
Instagram and that that's not deep
enough
I need something deeper and reddit gives
me my fix so let me take you on a
journey I think yeah this was know this
wasn't the popular page it was posted in
a couple of different threads but the
one that I follow is educational gifs or
gifts if you will and the title of the
post is this is how canning process is
done exclamation point and then it's a
repost or an embed post of from the
reddit thread manufacturing porn called
Kodai canning process exclamation point
you know when you hear canning process
it might sound boring but if you add an
exclamation point at the end
I'm listening this is like how its made
it so yeah it's a it's a video of a can
of what appears to what is beer I
couldn't tell what it was cuz it's like
it's not a candid I would recognize
maybe code I is a name-brand I actually
don't know so this video is cool because
yes it of course it loops but it shows
three different steps in the
manufacturing process before it loops so
it it starts and you see him like
spinning on the lid of a can and I never
really understood I was really drawn in
I never really understood that the top
of a can like where you pop it open like
that that's sealed on I just had never
thought about it right and then the
camera moves after it shows you a number
of these lids being slapped on the cans
then it moves earlier in the process and
shows you right before the know it
that's later in the process it twists
the can lid and spins off all the beer
foam and then it goes earlier in the
process and shows you all this foamy
beer coming out before the lid is
slapped on yeah I think this jiff that's
just looping in the wrong place or maybe
because this is the beginning coming in
coming in with the beer people beer
coming in well the foam then they scrape
the foam off and then they throw a lid
on and the way that the lid slides on is
just I never thought about that like
that you know because its contents under
pressure does that mean that the there's
it's extra carbonated when it's when it
goes in is that why like I would think
with that much foam at the top there
would be more foam underneath the
surface and so when you ended up getting
a can of beer it would have like an inch
missing of beer because the foam would
have just turned into liquid but it's
completely full I just don't understand
how this process leads to that because
it's like overflowing right there yeah
they fill it up to where the foam is all
the way at the top and then they smash
the lid down so there is some pressure
and there's problem
they from the carbonation of the beer or
whatever you would call it see see this
is where you're going and if you were a
commenter this is what you might comment
and if you knew that so you might ask
that question someone would come in and
answer the question and then the rest of
us would learn that so whenever I watch
a video like this first of all I'm
mesmerized by it and then I'm just I'm
like there's 343 comments under this
video
mm-hmm I wonder where it goes and I
wonder what most people have engaged in
which will rise to the top if you don't
use reddit I'm just giving you a little
background so it could be anything they
could be talking about anything in the
first comment the beginning of my
journey says f-word I'm not gonna say it
it's just not those machines must suck
to maintain so we got a debbie downer
right at the top of this thread people
talking about how unclean it is because
basically there's beer foam going all
over the can and then in the next step
they spin the can at a rapid aggressive
speed and then this beer foam goes
everywhere so this is what someone
commented and then it everybody seemed
to engage under this one comment yeah so
the so the person says those machines
must suck to maintain of course I'm like
yeah I was kind of thinking that myself
now that you mention it and then the
person says someone else responds sticky
smelly mess I don't forget that clearly
that is not really the case beer is a
perishable product those machines are
cleaned religiously because otherwise
beer won't have a long shelf life due to
contamination it can be sticky during
the shift but overall it's kept clean I
worked for a hotdog manufacturer and
every single machine was deconstructed
soaked up scrubbed and rinsed then
reassembled at the end of every shift at
this point I'm like dang I'm taking a
journey to the end of a hotdog shift in
there freaking disassembling the entire
machinery washing it all down I know you
got your going in other places but I
just like I have to say that
why can't they just like steam the whole
thing you know like why can't there just
be like a steam component that comes in
and just blast it with steam and soap
and stuff what can it be self-cleaning
well I don't understand why you can't
well you got to take it apart
surely that this premises this is a hell
everything is done crevices mint hot dog
and beer gets in crevices how dogs right
gets into more crevices than beer and
you can you can't get it out so now I'm
on this cleaning manufacturing lines
thread and I'm I'm all in like I was
actually surprised at myself at this
point that like I was so interested in
this and I will keep reading okay I have
an industrial engineering degree you
know it's a it's it's basically a degree
that teaches you not how to make things
not not how not to design things but
design how the things are made so it's
the manufacturer designing a
manufacturing process right once the
thing that you know you you want to
create has already been designed well
what's the most efficient or clean or
safe or all of the above way to actually
get that thing made get that beer canned
one of my favorite classes was we had
you know the manufacturing processes
class and we would just go and take
tours of factories way towards me just a
field trip class yeah field trip class
yeah so you got the hotdog manufacturer
talking about deconstructing soaping up
scrubbing rinsing reassembling the
machines at the end of every shift and
then someone commented and people say
Automation will take jobs away and then
funky credo comes in and says it already
did the company I work for was in
Ukraine due to cheap labor cost the
level of automation is low since it's
not cost-effective our facility made for
tons an hour of hot dogs using multiple
manufacturing lines and close to 100
people per shift directly on those lines
I toured a number of facilities in the
US
most are so automated that a single line
makes eight tons an hour which is twice
as much with only eight people directly
involved as opposed to a hundred and
then someone commented I bet those eight
people got a ton of to clean and it
probably doesn't all get done know I
used to work in a pastry facility doing
sanitation yes now we're we've gone from
beer to hot dog to pastry people working
the river he's coming out of the
woodwork and I am here for it
I noticed that pretty much everything
can be Power washed in most facilities
making it incredibly easy to clean see
this is the question you had why do they
have to take stuff apart really do you
really need to do that plus we had to
pass cleanliness inspections every
morning which involved multiple cotton
swab tests on every machine for food
bacteria we clean the entire facility
facility literally facility industrial
engineer here we clean the entire
facility with like three people versus
the 15 that worked at line needless to
say I'd far trust us cleaning since it
is typically all designed to be cleaned
and multiple tests are run before the
facility can even know because the
moment that you get bacteria on the
equipment and it's transferred to the
food you basically are completely shut
down your livelihood is gone so right
all the incentives are to maintain very
high standards and another commenter
comes in and talks about how in other
facilities that the machines do start to
clean themselves but they're still like
rigorous swabbing and it's happening
right you know I think I think I would
do good in a place that involved
rigorous swabbing but I would still be
very anxious like you'd probably never
find anything on your swab but even the
rigorous swabbing can easily be well not
easily will eventually be automated I
mean our steps can be automated the
rigorous rigorous swabbing Wigga with
swabbing will be automated right it
could be automated right a robot is
probably gonna be better at
you know evaluating the swab then just
some dude named bill and then
trepanation by 45 swoops in and expands
the convo there's an interesting albeit
slightly esoteric argument for
automation that suggests that once we as
a species get through the initial bumps
of steadily implementing it more and
more that humans will thus be able to
concentrate their lives more on their
truly passionate pursuits due to the
vast elimination of boring tedious tasks
that once we that once we're free of
manually having to quote waste our lives
performing the various tasks out of
necessity we'd have the opportunity to
become more in touch with our humanity
and spend our time pursuing the things
that we truly love and that a majority
of previous jobs that related to
performance that boring work would
translate towards less intensive
automation supervision or orchestration
etc obviously there's much much more
nuance to that sort of cultural
development but it does strike me as an
interesting is somewhat counter
intuitive notion don't you think I think
there's a lot of assumptions about human
behavior built into that yeah yeah there
haven't you seen wall-e
there is an assumption that we can once
we're freed up we'll be able to come
people will instinctively concentrate
their lives more on their truly
passionate pursuits
some people will yeah in wall-e as I
call it if memory serves me I don't
remember much of the plot but memory
serves you correct well much of the
dialogue because of you incorrect it
could miss I can it could deserve me
yeah there's a bunch of unhealthy people
just slopping around and in hover
recliners watching screens right
yeah robots doing everything I mean we
we spaceships
we have been the planet because it has
been destroyed we do have some data on
this right I mean there are people who
don't work for whatever reason I'm not
talking about people who want to work in
camp but be
who are choosing not to work they might
be retired I guess the retired community
is an example so you've got people who
are inactive and watched television eat
and watch television and become the
types of people that were featured in
wall-e and then you have another set of
the population that chooses to do
activities what might be referred to as
active leisure mm-hmm some things are
more active than others yeah it's so
you're using the retirement thing is an
analogous to well if your job was taken
away and then you had to find a new job
but you would be you would you would
have to find one you would have the
opportunity to find one that you were
more engaged in well then something that
was more monotonous that a robot could
do well and I like to I mean I like to
extrapolate things out to just the
logical conclusion right I mean a lot of
people make all kinds of arguments about
how automation is actually not going to
lead to unemployment and I don't really
want to get into it that's that's kind
of a Boris now I don't want to get into
that boring conversation I think that I
could just talk about cleaning
manufacturing the whole time if you
don't want to well I want to make sure
we're not boring well what I'm saying is
I don't want to debate whether or not it
automates gonna really be a problem for
people's jobs but I think that it's kind
of unavoidable if we don't which I
actually think that the chances that we
just exterminate ourselves because we
don't we're not dealing with global
crises in the way that we should we're
dividing as opposed to being unified and
coming together and solving problems
I think we'll probably straight I think
we will exterminate ourselves before we
actually get to this point but let's
just say people wake up and realize that
the world is falling apart and dying and
we actually need to do something about
it let's assume that humans well by the
way that is wall-e they were they left
earth right it was it was a bad to
abandon it yeah well let's just assume
that we wake up and figure it out then
it is inevitable that technology will
progress to a place where we have the
option
to get the robots to do all the stuff
that we don't want to do then let's
ignore like robots rights issues and
whether or not they have personhood
that'll become a debate it already is
whatever okay we'll let them worry about
that yeah but it is inevitable that
we'll get to a point where you don't
have to be the person to clean the beer
machines or the hotdog machine it's like
you could if you want to maybe but you
actually you probably won't even be
allowed to because you'll be way worse
at it and so in even the jobs that we
have like okay it isn't that far off
that I mean first of all there's already
a AI that's making YouTube videos and
they'll be the first completely AI
generated movie in however many years
and people will go to eventually the
stuff created by the robots and this may
take several generations many
generations but eventually the robots
will be able to create better than us
and you will enjoy a movie created by
robots from top to bottom more than the
one made by humans right everything will
be eventually replaced the the robots
might be able to do it better
eventually I I just have in what about I
can't believe that a purely creative
endeavor went would subject to so months
so much sensibility I'm saying ever be
this is way way way way way if our in
the future because replicating the human
mind and human intuition I mean did you
see the thing where this this could be I
don't know if this is just one of those
internet things that's not true but you
know the picture of the chihuahuas and
the blueberry muffins in the grid
oh yeah and somebody sent that to I
think a text hood that we're on and they
were like I think Jesse sent it AI is
not able to tell the difference between
the blueberry muffins and the Chihuahua
now if I squint it I couldn't either
right but you as a human you can look at
it and within about half a second you
can determine which ones
Chihuahua and which ones a blueberry
muffin apparently hey I still can't do
that right but they will be able to do
that if they can't already if that's
just a mean that doesn't isn't true what
I don't understand is why robots can't
push the button that says I am NOT a
robot on websites like now that seems
pretty simple yeah
you should be their robot really good
point I mean literally says I am NOT a
robot
and then there's one button it just
check it's like a checkbox fake it so
I'm pretty much under I'm eroding your
entire argument is that they can't check
the box man but they will I'm just
saying that there's gonna be all kinds
of ups and downs all kinds of arguments
ethical conundrums leading to a place
but eventually technology inevitably if
you don't exterminate yourself it
progresses to a place where something
you create is surpasses anything that
you are I just think that that's
inevitable so there will because it's in
cool there will be a point in which
you're like I don't have to contribute
essentially to society I mean the the
thread goes on to universal basic income
which I you know I don't really have the
appetite to go there except to say that
well if it some people say well if if
that exists then I actually don't know
but I presume that there's then an
argument on one side it's like well you
know then it gives people a padding that
then they're not going to do anything
you get you've got the you've got the
low level you've got the base level
income that you need to to thrive so it
really comes back to and we can make
this about us but what do you do if you
if you have free time I mean if you have
to find a job and there's no like
there's no financial cushion there then
hopefully we're creating enough jobs you
know where everybody can get one I just
doesn't make sense to me that everybody
will automatically be able to move to
what they're most passionate about but I
also don't know that most people if they
if they are financially secure enough I
think there's there's some people who
then like go wild with their path
some people who just go lazy yes and
personality dependent yeah and I
actually feel I feel like mine my
natural instinct is in is toward the
entropy of just laziness just falling
apart
mmm I don't think no I I don't think so
I think you'd get very frustrated with
yourself if you if you if you actually
did that with your leisure time but I'm
reading a book right now I've become
depressed yeah but I think I would have
to push through that I think I don't
think you would I think I'd have to go
through that Valley I'm reading a book
right now that I'm not gonna say what it
is because it might be a wreck once I
get through and decide that it's a wreck
and I wreck you know a wreck and effect
at the end of the show just say what
just no no and give it again no no I
don't know if it's good uh yeah I will
cause I feel like it might be a strong
recommendation but I have to I'm only
like a third through it but one of the
principles that is being discussed in
the book is essentially where people you
have this idea that okay well what I'm
going to do when I get old and I've and
I've you know I've done my work and it's
time to retire is I'm going to be as my
Instagram shout-out to read em see on
Instagram as my Instagram bio says
future international man of leisure
right and it's a joke that just came up
with you know it's kind of a non joke
it's a playful description and I think
it will turn some people against you
yeah and as a result of this
conversation and as a result of this
book I'm reading I actually think I'm
going to change that
yeah I definitely hate you because of it
now but so the implication is that okay
when I have free time I'm going to be a
man of and I would say active leisure
you know travel experiencing things or
whatever kitesurfer don't think I'm
gonna go there now shoulders II the
argument that this guy makes in the book
is that people who live lives of purpose
and have true joy are those who as
actually as they get older they actually
increase their commitments
to other people it might be a commitment
to a cause or a commitment to a
community or an organization or an
individual but essentially that people
who are the most satisfied and the most
purpose oriented are the people who have
commitments I got to be there for
something for or for somebody six nights
in a row and that's not what my six
nights in a row have been about but you
know what I'm saying yeah and that kind
of struck me I was like first of all
this isn't like this isn't fundamentally
a get goes goes against anything that I
already believe or think or want for my
life but it made me think differently
about that little quip in my Instagram
bio because I do like to think about hey
we're gonna travel and we're gonna do
this and he's like everyone thinks that
that's what they want to do but that
life gets pretty empty pretty quickly
and so I think that the real question
the ethical question when people have
this free time because listen we're just
we're talking in the we're assuming that
people are gonna have the option to be
like okay I get my universal basic
income and now I can play video games I
can good I can get lost in VR which is
that's going to be a huge cultural
problem is people getting just basically
living their lives online and then other
people will just binge watch them VR in
their lives right and but the other I
think the people who are gonna be truly
happy like you're talking about fighting
through this depression right like okay
if you commit yourself to dis personal
pursuits I'm gonna go do what I want to
do whether that's watch TV or go
kitesurfing it could be active I do
think that eventually you're gonna be
like I kind of just this there's not a
lot here this isn't what why am I here
humans are not I even still here yeah
and so the the principle in this book is
that we we think we're all about
independence but really were built for
interdependence and so I think that
there's this idea that like listen we we
evolved in community and like you go
back just a very very short period of
time to where we were living in these
like communities of like a hundred 150
individual
that all had a role and you were
contributing to each other's lives you
were involved in each other's lives
emotionally physically and you were
helping raise children when you're
getting old you were valued for your
perspective yeah your wisdom and so I
think that again if we don't exterminate
ourselves we get to this point where all
the robots are doing all the work the
only way we will survive as a species is
if we somehow replicate this community
that exists for our own health so you
know I'm saying like we will come up
with roles and interactions and
relationships for our own personal
well-being that may not even be they're
not contributing to like the GDP because
the robots are doing all that this just
becomes about just well-being amongst
people first of all and I got ton of
people that's something to pay billions
of people you can make a living doing
that more people in the world can
probably support but it doesn't have to
be charity I mean this there's
occupations associated with this and
more can be invented this is exactly
what I was getting at when I was like
aspirationally I want to be the type of
person that takes life by the horns you
know it's like what we don't my nanny
Lucille my mom's mom she worked her
entire life in a shirt factory right you
know and my aunt Vicki right beside her
aunt Vicki was a folder I believe and
nany was an inspector you know the
little sticker you get with a number
with the name on it well the number was
I Lucille Lucille was a number I don't
know maybe she was number nine she's
number one to me but there was that's
accountability in the factory that's why
they put the sticker there it's not for
anybody else just if something screwed
up then Nana gets a demerit but in it I
mean that is that that's red cap factory
on on the far side of Lillington across
from Birds driving a trailer where they
had the amazing burgers yeah and now
it's there's just a Burger King over
there and it sucks every day of her life
I mean like I'll need to ask her how
many years but like she did it longer
than Vicki right because or they
they say she's retired Ikki went to work
at the school that's well yeah but her
entire working life she worked in one
shirt factory the entire time right I
mean it's like we have this amazing job
where we're so creatively fulfilled and
every day is different I mean our
calendars filled up and we're told where
we have to be in what we have to do and
we have to fill all these slots and we
get grumpy but we have we are doing our
passions like oh yeah there's few people
on the planet that the percentage of
their time is dead is dedicated as
highly as ours is to our hour actually
our passions yeah and maybe that's a
factor but I don't for me but I think
it's more still a personality type that
like it's probably both that like okay
if if I had time I would just like veg
out and maybe that's because I'm so
fulfilled and maybe the average person
who isn't would more likely pursue that
than not but I want to be the type of
person that as I continue to gain space
in my life to make decisions with what I
want to do that it's things that are
healthy but also meaningful and and
beyond myself you got I mean you can
save the wreck but just tell me to name
it a book I feel like I'd like to maybe
read this book it's called the second
mountain the second mountain okay
yes I'm interested in that I think that
because I don't know that I'm that type
of person I mean like even this weekend
it's like I'm going camping with the
kids but it's because our friend Nick
said hey I'm going camping with my kids
do you want to come and I was like they
probably are gonna want to come and then
I asked the kids and they wanted to go
and I'm like yes cuz I didn't want to
take them I didn't want to force them
yeah I was so happy but I was a little a
tinge of like self-judgement that I
wouldn't have gone camping unless I was
invited like I had the time
and and my family has the appetite but
it would have but I didn't take the
initiative to do it and I want to be the
type of person that's like continues to
do you know not just sit on my butt I
don't
I'm heart maybe I'm - I think so I think
you're being too hard on yourself
because I I think that climb that second
mountain like when you're wide early
when your wife texted me and my wife a
picture of you lounging next to your
pool this past Saturday and she said
this is post nude swim link and you just
had a towel judge recently and yet a
towel draped over your nether regions
and she was like still nude by the way I
didn't judge you man do you know what I
thought to myself man I should take a
nude swim right now I should be in my
pool naked and then lounging next to it
that's what I thought sometimes a man
needs to swim naked man yeah and if you
zoom in I mean look at how you look so
contented look how content on it right
now
don't worry Kiko I'm taking a screenshot
for you so you can see my contented
naked body lounging by my pool so share
it with the people cuz I think so I'm
passionate about it again cuz I think
that I don't feel bad about that I think
that so much of what makes us happy is
trying to find a way to interact with
the modern world in a way that is sort
of in Symphony with our actual biology
you know what I'm saying and that's just
a I think I talked about this and you're
tired of it you don't want to hear me
talk about it again when I say it all
the time about you know Stone Age
hardware and modern age software and
that's those are kind of the source of
so many of our problems but I do I just
feel that way and so like you what
you're doing when you lay next to your
pool after you've had like we work hard
yeah we have a great job we it's not
it's not a hard labor
job my hands are soft I'm saying the
tips of my fingers are the might the
tips of my left hand fingers are pretty
callous because I play the guitar but my
hands are soft you know I used to shake
hands with my uncle Jake who was a pipe
welder and that dude it was just like
going into the sandpaper section of the
Home Depot and just brushing up against
it I mean his hands were it was like it
was something other than human skin it
was like boulders wrapped in sandpaper
yeah
wrapped around your hand it was just
like touching a man wearing a glove and
you know he doesn't have a glove on hand
has become a glove and that man worked
hard lived hard died young we don't live
that kind of life well he shouldn't have
stared right into the welding arc I
don't think that's what it was he did he
took the the appropriate safety measures
I believe we didn't wear gloves we have
a pretty we get to do it like you said
privilege out the wazoo we get to do
what we want we make our own schedule
but we have committed ourselves
thoroughly to these aspirations and
these dreams on this probably delusional
level and we end up spending a lot of
time on it so when I get home at night
or on the weekends like I'm exhausted
because emotional exertion is a real
thing like we're putting our hearts
Souls into what we're doing and
performing and creating and it is
exhausting and it does have a physical
toll so I don't you shouldn't feel bad
about that I think well I think what
we're really talking about is when when
we don't have those obligations like cuz
I kind of feel like I know what I would
do like if all of a sudden I everything
was everything was good everything was
taken care of all the people that I love
are taken care of and you know I could
just like step away from everything that
we built and I could just like I can do
anything that I want what I would most
likely do like my first inclination is
to just fill my time with other creative
endeavors but things that don't
necessarily have to be a commercial
right and maybe things that wouldn't
even be enjoyed by lots of people it
might just be like oh I'm gonna create
in this particular way right or paint or
whatever or I've got this passion
project now I want to do that and I
think that even that would become kind
of unfulfilled at some point right
because unless I was able to direct
those passions and what I can do
creatively into like greater good to
support something or support someone I
think eventually those things wouldn't
be very fulfilling right now I think the
thing that keeps us going and keeps us
so busy is again and I do think it's
slightly delusional and that's probably
a good thing is we just have this idea
that like oh the next thing that we're
gonna create is the best thing we've
ever created and we're gonna find some
way to get somebody to help us make it
and we have this sort of rolling list of
things that we feel like we have to do
but eventually we're gonna get to the
end of that we're gonna one of the two
things is going to happen we're gonna do
the things on that list and then realize
that they're really not any different
from a personal satisfaction point than
anything we've ever created and there's
no real joy and happiness there be
probably more likely we're gonna get
older before we're gonna lose the
ability to do them before we're able to
do them I mean that might be a
pessimistic viewpoint but it's just like
the greatest fear is that our best work
is behind us but I'm also sort of like
using historical data to come to that
conclusion that you know typically
you're moving into your 40s it's not
like you're I mean I hope I still
believe that our best work is ahead of
us but anyway we're gonna at some point
we're gonna get to a place where we did
either done it or it we weren't able to
do it and now we got to make a decision
about what what is life gonna be that's
the more that's the more pressing
question for me personally because I
feel like we're going to be answering
that question for ourselves
way that maybe this is society as a
whole is gonna be answering that
question in the distant future because
we've got privilege to do it I feel like
you need to ask yourself that question
much less but the average person might
need to ask themselves the question much
more like how do I engage my passion for
the and then dah dah dah
potentially for the greater good let me
continue with the thread here because
the with every with every tangent there
is a recenter II so after that let's see
oh this one guy shared this anecdote or
job I'll quickly share just I worked as
a controls engineer at a factory that
made sports drinks for a few years beer
wieners pastries sports drinks this is
my passion I'm gonna go back to
Industrial Engineering I think that's
what I'm learning the factory was
originally built in the 70s and had been
constantly upgraded it was eerie because
you'd be in a million square foot
factory plus warehouse that ran 24/7
producing over 2 million cases of drinks
per month and there'd be 20 to 40 people
on duty per shift so you could be on the
factory floor and potentially not see
another human being for hours I would
love to go into a facility like that the
break room and parking lot were all
sized for hundreds of people so everyone
would be on lunch break and it'd only be
a small corner of the room with people
in it it always felt a little bit eerie
so when they built this plant there was
more people in the process yeah but like
back back in the 70s yeah million square
foot facility so now there's like 20 to
40 people
anyway Automation had eliminated
hundreds of jobs over the decades and
continued to eliminate the remaining
ones including maintenance technicians
and housekeeping staff as the machines
got more reliable or came with more
capabilities but and at this point I
started to think man
this is this will be cool in a movie
like this is a cool setting for a movie
like it's not even in the future this is
now so we don't have to make like a
sci-fi film to do this but I'm just
planting a seed here that like huge
factory with like 20 people working in
it
hmm let's find a factory let's write a
whole movie in a cavernous Factory
we're only you only see people once a
day and then you go to the break room
and like they're all huddled in the
corner eating starved for connection
that's Irie man
that's cool I like it yeah so that's
that's a movie idea that I got and then
we come to it
there's there's more stuff under people
talking about like that guys post but
then I'm keep I keep scrolling I'm about
to fall asleep at this point like boy
I've I've been in the canning process
I've bet I've been power washing
equipment I've been thinking about the
like my future and engaging my passions
and the future of society I've been
thinking about a movie idea and right
before I shut my little phone and shut
my little eyes I read it
somebody comments that was my nickname
in middle school and if you scroll all
the way back up to the top you'll
remember that the second comment was
sticky smelly mess which someone said
that was my nickname in middle middle
school okay
that's interesting first comment
underneath that red question mark and
then other people are coming about it of
course you say that was my nickname in
high school but on GMM a lot and I was
in me I was bolted I almost sat up on my
bed like all of a sudden I was like
totally awake again yeah I was like I'm
like you know him I'm deep I know him
yeah I'm deep in this reddit thread has
nothing to do with me you or us and all
of a sudden there you are someone who
knew you and that dumb catch
raise em thought they need to associate
themselves with is a pretty good it's
kind of like what she said if she said
it kind of always works it's exactly
like that in that except for the fact
that if you said that's what she said on
our show a lot and people thought that
you came up with it that's the thing I
find funny is that you didn't come up
with I don't think that was my nickname
in high school and you don't you have
not claimed to do that but there are
people in the world and there are people
on this reddit thread apparently who's
so associated with you that I think they
may believe that you came up with the
catchphrase I think I could convince
myself that I came up memory you need
you can control you can control that
kind of thing well this person got it
wrong you said high school you say hi so
middle school sticky and smelly mess I
don't know is a little bit more of a
middle school thing look at right there
question mark Rhett Rhett but that
didn't get much traction didn't get any
traction no no you got to up votes okay
I appreciate that it's time to give a
wreck in effect as we wrap down this
episode check baby check I guess it's my
turn to give a wreck yeah you know what
I didn't come very prepared today I
would like to highly recommend a book
called second Mountain it's a mom I
haven't started reading it yet but Rhett
was telling me about it and you I'm only
a third into it I don't I don't really a
third into it but from what he tells me
I don't like to reckon I'm gonna read -
you're not recommending it I'm
recommending it but you guys still my
recommendation well I'm stealing it I'm
stealing it second Mountain by rupert
Monday I don't know come on man what's
this I got a gift it well it's just
really a wreck
yes what you don't have another wreck
David Brooks man David Brooks second
Mountain exhausted the second Mountain I
also recommend second
a 20-18 american romantic comedy film
directed by peter segal and written by
elaine goldsmith thomas because that
came up on your when you did a google
search for a second yes hashtag ear
biscuits let us know what you think
about automation the future of society
following your passions and somehow i
don't normally do this but i just want
to encourage you take a moment even if
it's just a moment today to engage in a
personal passion don't wait and
definitely stop back up before you
become a sticky and sweaty mess or
sticking it smelly to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]